thank you thank you so yeah I don't have
a Windows machine I have a Linux machine
so it's always a nice surprise that that
an external display works so great it's
a good start right so I'm marching I'm
going to talk about a hybrid recommender
systems in Python and I'm going to start
well I'm gonna start by saying I'm a
data scientist at list a list is a this
is a fashion company what we do is we go
all over the internet and get people's
products fashion products from all sorts
of different retailers websites with
their permission by the way and we we
take them all together we aggregate them
all in one place so that at least you
can you can follow your favorite
designers and retailers and buy
everything in one place and and
hopefully get a nice experience out of
it
and at least I mainly build
recommendations but I have doubled in
other systems like both you know
backends and even in front and in
ancient times when a very very tiny
startup at the moment I'm gonna see
recommendations okay I'm going to talk
about hyper recommenders what they are
and why you might want one especially if
you're small if you to startup you're
almost certain you want one okay so
collaborative filtering is the workers
of recommender systems who knows what
collaborative filtering is most people
know carburetor filtering is but I'm
going to go over it anyway because it's
always useful so what you do is use
historical data on Co purchasing
behavior to recommend items to people so
this is the typical way it's expressed
is users from what X also bought some
product Y and so the way you often do it
is you you express it as a user item
interaction matrix so the rows I users
and the columns are items and then if in
the first row we've got one in the in
the topmost top-left corner that means
that user zero purchase product 0 and
then they didn't purchase product 1 and
and maybe they purchased the last
product you have from your database so
that's how we can express express the
sort of data by in this case if you have
a binary matrix that's probably in some
sort of interaction I click or maybe a
purchase
and in the end in the simplest case
that's already enough to make
recommendations so basically you find
similar users by calculating distance
between the rows that represent them so
in this case we have let's say three
users and user they're the first user
it's not very similar at all to user
number two because well in the entries
that we can see they didn't actually
share any purchases so from that you can
refer they're not very similar whereas
the first user in the last user well
let's say they all made three purchases
so they out of these three purchases
they share to don't share one so if you
want to make recommendations for the
first user well what you might do is
find the last users the most similar
user and say well product this product
we should recommend to the first suitors
as well because the other very similar
is also voltage so that's the simplest
way of doing it and all you need is this
this sort of sparse matrix of
interactions so how you would actually
do it is you do you take all the rows
and you compute some sort of similarity
metric the easiest one will be cosine
distance between the rows and then you
pick out the most similar users and you
recommend those items that those users
bought that they the user you're
targeting hasn't bought and you wage the
recommendations by how similar the users
are so the most similar user is the more
their purchases should influence your
recommendations for the user interested
in
so that's collaborative filtering
basically you use past interactions to
recommend new items most applications of
this actually use some sort of matrix
factorization so you don't actually use
the the distance computations you don't
use it raw matrix but what you say is
well we have this very sparse matrix
which is very lots of entries lots of
dimensions but it's actually an
expression of a lower rank sort of lower
rank structure and you represent that
matrix by the multiplication of two
lower ranked matrices ump which as rows
have delays and vectors for your users
and items so you fit this matrix to
approximate your your original
interaction matrix as closely as
possible and out of that so I'll just
imposing the lower rank structure you
get so you get miss
entries filled in it's like a sort of
reproduction problem
and this works reasonably well or rather
remarkably well if you have a lot of
data so there are a couple of nice
properties one is domain agnostic you
don't need to know anything about the
users and items and this is particular
useful if let's say you're providing
recommender systems to people
doesn't matter who comes to you you
don't need to know what the domain is
you just deployed the algorithm that you
know that works and you find you don't
need to know whether you're trying to
sell newspapers or fashion products or
soft drinks it works for you just fine
it's easy to understand and implement
it's even easy to explain to users you
can actually explain your algorithm to
your end-users on your website and
they'll be happy with that it's the
chief component of the Netflix prize
winning ensemble so if you're not
familiar the Netflix prize a couple of
years ago almost ten years ago actually
on Netflix so we have this algorithm for
recommendations can you can you please
come to us and submit solutions that
will improve it and if you do we'll pay
you a large sum of money and the my
matrix factorization is one of the one
of the key and key algorithms that came
out of this for better or for worse and
the last thing is it yields nice low
dimensional item representations it's
useful if you want to do related
products so if you wanted to if you just
had this parse interaction matrix and
you wanted to find out which items are
similar to other items you would have to
do these very high dimensional space dot
products which is in which isn't very
easy to do when it's not very handy if
you use matrix factorization your factor
matrices they have these nice compact
dense vectors you can just multiply them
together and that's that's very handy
but what if your data is sparse what if
you have a huge product inventory what
if you have short-lived products let's
say you want to do recommendations on
news articles and really the only
relevant news articles are the news
articles that appeared in the last four
hours or four days and then having this
you know in the four hours or four days
unless you have a huge amount of users
you're not going to accumulate a huge
amount of Ko interaction data
if yeah and then once they're older than
four hours you don't care anymore so
even if you have a lot of data they're
not really a valid target for
recommendations if you have lots of new
users so let's say you're a startup or
you're growing massively or maybe you're
not a startup you're not going massively
but you don't you don't really record
information about who your users are
maybe they most of the browsing sessions
are anonymous and they're not actually
logged in so so then you don't have that
much data on who those users are you
don't know what they bought previously
you don't and if you don't know this you
can't really apply collaborative
filtering very easily because you don't
know who they are don't know what the
purchases were you can't find a similar
users yeah most users haven't bought
most items haven't been bought if you
have very sparse data can't compute
similarities so in a problem like this
when you don't have when you have a very
sparse interaction matrix when you have
new items new users if you try to do
matrix factorization you're not going to
go very far it will perform no better
than random and I'm speaking from
personal experience at least you know
fashion we have Lowe's in them because
we're an aggregation we have loads and
loads of new products coming onto the
site every day we also use we also deal
in fashion and if fashion you have a
certain number of products which are
sort of evergreens you always want to
sneakers or my t-shirts but but a lot of
products are seasonal they're the newest
collection and they're only really it's
only really useful to you and to your
customers when they're fresh so if you
want to do traditional matrix
factorization in that setting you're not
going to go very far and in getting to
waste your time if somebody has any
stories that contravene you what I'm
saying out I'd be very happy to talk to
you later so what you can do instead is
use content-based models what you can do
is collect metadata about items so you
start learning about things so you know
this news articles on a certain topic or
contains certain words and this is or
this fashion item is a shoe or a dress
and then you can in the simplest case
construct a classifier for each user so
you take data on what a given user
interacted with in the past and then
basically build a classification model
for them so this user always clicked on
articles about football there
this is an article football therefore
should be recommended that user and you
can do this using nd to all you you just
take the interaction let's say fit
escalate just two classifiers for you
for every user and and you have a
reasonable content based model to make
recommendations it has a couple of
problems you need to have plenty of data
for each user so if your user is new or
did not logged in you can't really
compute anything for them because you
don't know their past interactions and
if you want to compute a model pair
every user what you'd better have a lot
of interactions because otherwise
there's nothing to know data to estimate
your models from there if you compute
separate models for all the users there
is no information sharing across users
so if say all football all people who
are interested in football articles
they're also interested in cricket
articles which they're probably not bad
there might be if you said if you fit
separate models there's no information
showing you cannot share these
statistical strengths from one user to
another so you have to you have to get
lots of data for every user and the last
thing is if you want to do related
products or related articles it doesn't
provide compact representations fighting
similarity so then the best you could do
I guess is some sort of tf-idf IDF
approach so for articles you would take
the terms and and and do cosine distance
in that space but that doesn't always
work so this is an example from my
domain so a good evening dress and
Givenchy ballgown they're all that well
reasonably similar things they're sort
of expensive formal dresses you might
wear to it to a ball so you know good
changing all she'd they're both
expensive designers so that's a
dimension of similarity they should you
should be able to capture an evening
dress and ball gown they're probably not
the same but they're quite close they're
both things you would wear for a formal
occasion but if you just use a TF idea
for a term matching model these are
completely dissimilar they don't share
any tokens and if you if you just have
content-based models unfortunately you
would have especially in short documents
you would have to deal with this problem
may be a longer documents you would have
some sort of topic models but on short
documents like product descriptions
you would have this problem so the
solution is use a hybrid model that
tries to combine the strengths of
collaborative and content-based
recommenders and the disclaimer here is
this is what I try to sell you my own
model so please don't boo me I think
it's a good solution please please baby
bear with me so the package is called
light film it's a vote of matrix
factorization but instead of estimating
latent specters for every user and every
item we estimate latent vectors for used
an item metadata so let's say I have a
general XI ballgown and instead of
estimating one latent vector for this I
estimate latent vectors for Givenchy
football and for gown or for some
combination of those and and then use
those instead and the benefit that is in
many applications you will have far
fewer features metadata features was
distinct metadata features that you
would see that is useful because now
your interaction matrix your data you're
using that to estimate a model with far
far far fewer parameters and that allows
you to do things you wouldn't be able to
do with with traditional matrix
factorization alone but user an item IDs
can also be included in it as you
metadata so then you know let's say you
would have a Givenchy ballgown these are
metadata features but you could also
have an ID for that product and then you
estimate representation for follow for
some of these parameters yeah so that's
that's how it works so we her Jewish
ballgown so and there are presented
later representation for that for that
product is the element wise some of
presentations even see ball and gown and
you can do the exact same thing for
users so let's say you have a female
user with ID 100 and you basically their
representation in your model is the
element wise some of the representation
of female and ID 100 and the prediction
for a user item pair is given by the
inner product of the representation so
take the two vectors or you say rather
take the vectors for the for one
representations squash them together
with a sum take the user presentation
caution together with some and then take
the dot product of those and maybe some
sort of link function on top and that's
a prediction which is very similar to
traditional major matrix factorization
models for those of you who are more
familiar with neural networks this is
basically two independent fully
connected layers one with user the other
was item features as inputs and connect
it's connected via dot product so the
benefits to this far fewer parameters to
estimate you can make predictions for
new items in users so let's say in a
traditional MF model you would have a
new item coming in you don't have any
metadata so you just know it's an ID you
know your max ID plus one that's your ID
and can you make recommendations for
that thing well you can't you don't have
any past interaction data you don't have
a latent representation for that product
and you won't be able to estimate it for
a while
until you guys until you've accumulated
an update on that product whereas for
this system you you can get reasonably
good representations from the get-go
just by taking the metadata of their
product taking their legend
representations and smooshing them
together I captured synonymy so in the
example I gave earlier with with evening
dresses if your user interactions
suggest that evening dresses and ball
gowns are similar things so let's say
sessions they looked at ball gowns also
looked at evening dresses or maybe they
bought them together then that will be
captured in the latent space of the
metadata embeddings so so that sort of
captures that alleviates a problem with
with traditional tf-idf produces nice
then this item representations so you
can do your nearest neighbor search and
know dimensions and if you instead of
using metadata features if you just
stick use an item IDs and you know
feature matrices it reduces to the
standard MF model as a special case yeah
and that's actually quite nice quite a
nice feature of this model because what
it means is it will be it will work well
on a range of problems so from your
extremely sparse things when you don't
have very much metadata a very much
interaction data and then you need me to
use metadata to get
it will work well there but it will also
work well on intermediate problems where
you don't have quite enough let's say
you have a fair amount of users who are
warm start but some new cold start users
it will work there but it will also work
very well in traditional high high
density zeta scenarios because it just
reduces to a traditional model so you
can use it without fear that's probably
so just a simple example like the
cross-validation data set so this is the
the part of the stack stack exchange
Network for like statistics and machine
learning questions and we we take the
data from there they publish all the
data you can download it from the
internet and it's trying to predict
which questions will use this answer and
trying to write basically have it take a
user and try to recommend to them
questions that they might be able to
post answers for
it's a ranking talk so we'll measure the
area under curve which this is a binary
chart so basically this could be
interpreted as saying well what is if we
have a you see of one than a hundred
percent of the things that people could
actually answer will be ranked above
above the things that it couldn't answer
if we have half then basically our
rankings random we cannot differentiate
between things that they're able to
answer and the things are unable or
didn't answer so with fewer
collaborative filtering the round light
FM on that and then the AUC is 0:43
which is what is somewhat surprising
you'd expect which is 0.5 but it's it's
worse than random I presume that this is
because you've got very little
interaction data and lots and lots of
parameters in massively over fits to the
training set and then it's horrible in
the test set but this is I this would be
reproducible if you try to apply
traditional MF models to this sort of
sparse problem this is what you'd get
you to get an ace your 0.5 your model
will be no better than random don't
bother a pure constant based solution
and actually performs reason--you
reasonably well and just fit a separate
logistic regression model for each user
that falls reasonably well the reason
for this is the majority of questions
are answered by paying
highly active users that doesn't so
there is enough data for every user to
to tell what they're going to answer
because
majority of questions answered by a
small set of very prolific users but it
does a lot better but it could we can do
even better with a hybrid model so with
the hybrid solution we get an ACC of
0.71 which is the best result and it's
not very scientific comparison but we
also get tagged embeddings as an extra
benefit so if you remember the the way
you do it is you guesstimate embeddings
the latent factors for your meta data in
this case the metadata are the tags that
you tell you out to the questions so
let's say we have a question on on
Bayesian methods and you may talk with
MCMC or placing inference and these are
the metadata features that you use to
fit these models and if you run if you
run the light of a model using using the
hybrid solution you get these bits
tagged similarity sort of information so
if you if you take the the tag Bayesian
and if you try to get the the other tags
that are most similar to them the
embeddings are most similar the cosine
distance ends you will get em CMC and
variational base which is just
reasonably close if you if you try
survival you get stuff like Cox model
odds ratio and kaplan meier which are
all terms related to survival models so
that's quite nice let's say if you if
you if you run the stock exchange
network and if you wanted to encourage
people to to tag the questions well tag
the questions in a way that would allow
people to answer them better you might
well use a system like this well let's
say they put MC MC and then then you go
oh do you want to tag this as Bayesian
as well or do you want to tag this as
variational base and maybe maybe that
would lead people to to tag tag
questions now in a more relevant mother
if you're familiar with NLP results this
is quite similar to word to vehicle
glove all the other fancy quote-unquote
deep learning methods and that's because
they're both essentially matrix
factorization algorithms they you know
were two vectors looks as the word
co-occurrence matrix this looks at say
the user generated cope urges matrix but
but but the the key of the algorithm is
is the same so it's not surprising they
get very similar results
so in summary if you have lots of new
users or new items you will benefit from
a hybrid algorithm I recommend trying it
and even if you don't face cold start
and use Python you might still want to
use lighter fem for the following
reasons it's easy to use and sort of
Escalon esque interface doesn't adhere
to all the norms but to to enough of
them that you would find it familiar so
that's that's how you use it you
installed from pip you - from light
fermion polite affirm you specify
specify a model object and then we
specify a special nots function that I
can I'll briefly mention later
you specify learning rate the model is
fit using stochastic gradient descent I
specify learning schedule so that sir
that's because the model is fit using
per parameter learning rates would give
you give you faster convergence and make
them slightly slightly more robust -
hyper parameter choices and you
specified the the latent dimensionality
of your model and then you just run it
and wear interactions is a size fast
matrix and these are also side by sparse
matrices and you can run it on on
machines with multiple cores which is
also quite nice yeah it's quite fast
it's written in this item it supports
multiple training via hog wild hog wild
is or asynchronous stochastic gradient
descent is basically stochastic gradient
descent that exploits the fact that you
are dealing with a model that has sparse
data so every parameter is updated not
every parameter is updated in every with
every example so basically you run
multiple threads and they just write to
the part to the parameter parameter
array without any locking and that
allows you to do do do it very fast and
doesn't doesn't really impair
performance so at least we've run this
with success without any loss of
accuracy on 20 calls on a big machine
ooh 20 calls and it does it does work
quite well it uses learning to rank
losses it's likely more than two but I'm
just going to mention these so this is
that while learning to rank so
traditional matrix factorization models
or the ones that sort of fields started
with what they did were was predict
ratings
in the Netflix prize you would you would
rate an item on the scale of one-to-five
and and the original model said we're
going to make the recommendations and
the basis of predicting these ratings
correct so you would use output score
from 1 to 5 for a given user item pair
and then you would you would rank the
possible recommendations according to
your predicted score but that's not
actually how recommend the system's work
the way recommender systems work is you
present a user with a with a ranked list
of alternatives and then if if you
really care about is the top of the list
it doesn't matter if your model gets
things wrong the tail of the list
because the user never sees the tail of
the list so you so what you do is you
use these learn to rank approaches to -
firstly reflect the fact that you
actually care about a ranked list of
alternatives and secondly to make the
make the fitting procedure better for
the top of the list so BPR is I could
it's called Bayesian personalized rating
and it's quite an established technique
now basically what it does is it it has
a triplet loss you take a user you take
an item that we know that user liked and
we take an item that we I don't know the
user didn't like or we don't know
whether they usually would like and
basically what we try to do is make this
call for the item that's a known
positive higher than the negative so it
has this you know all drink type of
thing what we care about is that the
ordering is right that we don't inverse
invert the ranking and warp is a
slightly more complicated variant on
that idea it's it's also triplet loss
but it picks the triplets in a very
intelligent way so what it does is take
a user and then take an item that we
know they liked and take in sample a
random negative item from all the other
items and then say well this random item
that we sampled do are we scoring it
higher than the thing that we know the
user liked if you're not scoring it
higher then you just move on you sample
another item and say are we scoring this
item higher and you do this until you
find an item which you where ranking is
inverted so the negative item out scores
the positive item and then you say well
in this case the model is wrong
and then you perform a stochastic
gradient descent update to make the
ranking to correct this ranking
conversion so that works remarkably well
even compared to Vpr it's a very clever
system and it may be slightly slower to
train but it really gives you much
better results
yes that's I guess that's what I was
just talking about from it again this is
from like a neural network perspective a
triplet loss is like a Siamese Network
whose shadow and shared weights
yeah with triplet loss if you're
familiar with neural networks that will
that will sound familiar
and finally we've got parameter learning
rates so other grab another Delta again
that's something that's used in the
various neural network optimizes what it
does is in stochastic gradient descent
you have this hyper parameter called
learning rate which basically governs
how how quickly your parameters update
as you fit your model and what you might
not want to do is make all the
parameters update at the same rate
because let's say you have you have the
intercept which is updated on every
single iteration and you know after a
while it will have converged to a
reasonably optimal solution you don't
want to keep updating it very often so
you want to reduce the learning rate for
that parameter on the other hand in
sparse data you may have lots of
parameters which are updated very
infrequently let's say for a very rare
feature and then you might want to keep
the learning rate quite high for that
parameter so that the model keeps gets
to a reasonably optimal solution for all
the common parameters but still keeps
learning and reasonably fast rate for
the rare parameters and what both of
these give you and the choice is there
just to UM to pick the one that works
better for your particular problem yeah
you install it from pip it's on github
I'm happy to fix things you may have
problems if you run I was ten but I'll
try to try to help you out but if you're
running Linux work out of the box and oh
there is a docker container so if you'll
know it's ten and use docker
just pull the pull the docker file a
docker compose build and
and work and that's the end of my talk
thank you very much yeah hi very nice
talk thank you
just a simple question are you aware of
SVD feature it's a model that seems to
be very similar to what you just
proposed I want to know if there is any
difference but I'm not familiar with it
we can't discuss it later
Thanks is there I guess what I should
say this isn't you shouldn't think this
is particulars an algorithm it's I said
it's just basically here you know a
neural network a triplet loss connected
in the middle but but but it's it's
probably down to very many
implementations thank you hi thanks for
the talk
I imagine that you have a website which
has a JavaScript or Java back-end and
you have quite some traffic so how how
do you integrate a python-based
recommender system in your website but
also make it skill yeah so what we do
actually is we have this it's a good
question Dowdell two answers to this
so we without there two two systems that
we that we use one is for full ranking
so we have these feeds of products and
rank them for every user and for every
sort of context that they might be in
and the second problem is related
products we have one product and you
want to find drugs that are similar in
the latent space to that product and we
use the sort of related solutions for
both and the way we do it is we we fit a
model using using this algorithm behind
this implementation and then we get the
parameters out and compute the
representations and we stick them in
Postgres and then in Postgres we've got
loads of custom C extensions which
basically do dot products and newest
neighbor searches in C in Postgres which
sounds scary but it works remark
well in you know I'm happy to talk about
that offline but basically fit the model
in Python offline then take the
parameters out stick them in Postgres
rights and see and you're golden I have
a question is that how do you deal with
the time effect for example somebody
bought product two years ago it doesn't
mean that still he likes that type of
product how do you update give the
higher priority or today more descent
transactions than the two years ago
right I mean I guess you could you could
have a two-fold answer one is you just
use heuristics to get around this sort
of thing so let's say you maybe you want
to fit your model over a rolling window
or maybe you want to decay past
observations and include them as let's
say whether there's something procedure
where you may include them with a
certain probability and the probability
gets lower as these observations get
older so that's that's one answer like
when you're doing a production system
maybe that's good enough for you I guess
if you're a researcher I mean it's a
really important problem for you then
maybe you'd want to adapt the fitting
procedure or the you know or your
objective function to reflect that sort
of you know the the temporal nature of
your data you know and for warp for
instance maybe maybe you know maybe
there's something procedure that it uses
could be could be changed in such a way
as to us to help satisfy that objective
but but I don't have any particular
insights on this
hi I have a sort of general question
about the module and a specific instance
of that so does the does your library
have facilities to help with testing
different modeling approaches and then
in particular I'm curious about effects
on diversity of the recommendations
between your hybrid approach and CF
especially maybe across different
metadata possibilities and how that
might affect diversity and popularity
and the results Thanks right
does the package have any facilities for
evaluation the answer to this is no I
guess there were two reasons one reason
is you this is packaged as one thing
let's just let's just keep it to
estimating the model the second reason
is you can like using the rest of the
Python data ecosystem you can you can
use scikit-learn and it has all the you
know all the evaluation you need as a UC
and as I think it has in DCG so you can
you can run your own solution with them
it's like I I see where you're coming
from because it's slightly painful and
you know I do it and I know it's painful
but I think every moment you have to
look somewhere else in terms of
diversity I think I think you're right
that if using metadata especially just
metadata you will your results could be
predictable and like well you discovered
that this user likes shoes and you know
they're going to get shoes and you're
not going to get some of this stuff that
you get from like pure collaborative
filtering approaches where maybe some
very unintuitive relationships emerge
maybe you wouldn't get that but but this
is designed for settings where you have
so little data you couldn't get those
relationships out anyway so maybe
diversity isn't as good but as you sort
of have bigger problems
one more thank you
after listening your presentation which
was very good thank you was very
powerful and it was kind of a solution
that we were looking for but in a
different sector with different industry
which is real estate when it comes to
real estate it's not like people liking
books or clothes it's a little bit
different because location comes in
place and when location comes in place
and you don't just look at an area may
be nearby area some other things come in
what do you think about you being able
to use your solution in in property
portal recommendation I mean I think I
think the metadata would be will be
quite useful so let's say you have you
have a property in a particular area and
let's say you you denote a district as a
buy new feature then you would get an
embedding for that district which would
be close in the Dayton's face to the
embeddings for other districts that are
relevant for users so let's say if they
they look at the center of Amsterdam and
some sort of I don't know Amsterdam but
some nearby out skip you know and the
people look at properties and in both of
these places together then this will be
reflected in in your in your embeddings
having said that geographical data
probably has a lot more structure to it
than just just this sort of stuff so
maybe you would want something in you
know that that reflects this
geographical structure maybe just binary
encodings of locations and one hooding
encoding of encoding the locations
wouldn't be the best solution
well let's think think much in this case